Good morning, everyone. I'm Alex Bui, co-director
of the BD2Ks Center's Coordination Center.
Welcome to another BD2K Data Science seminar.
So last time, we actually concluded section
three, which provided an overview of computing,
and we heard about some of the work that NIH
is doing in developing cloud-based infrastructure
to support biomedical big data science. Today,
we actually started a new section, section
four, which is focused on data modeling and
in inference. And any of you who have had
to work with big data datasets will appreciate
the challenges that are associated with both
understanding the data, and using it to uncover
patterns.
So over the next few weeks, we'll have speakers
talking about a range of techniques that are
related to modeling inference tests. And to
kick off this section, we're joined by Dr.
Fafael Irizarry, a professor of biostatistics
at Harvard in the school of Public Health,
and a member of the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
His work focuses on genomics and computational
biology problems.
In particular, he's worked on the analysis
microarray next generation sequencing and
genomic data. Dr. Irizarry has developed several
online courses on data analysis that are offered
through HarvardX, including data analysis
for the life sciences, and genomic data analysis.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Irizarry
this morning. Dr. Irizarry, thank you for
joining us today. The floor is yours.
Thank you. Thank you for inviting me. All
right, so a quick overview. Can everybody
hear me? Just double checking. Yes? OK.
Yes.
All right, great. So as a quick overview,
so you know what's coming, I'm going to divide
this into two parts. I'm going to very quickly
review some basic inference and modeling since
this is what the lecture is about. What I
want to do more than give an introduction
of introductory material is to show how I
use it in my research to put it in context.
I'm going to show two parts, one, somewhat
simple inference, basic inference, and then
the second one a little bit more advanced,
more complex, relating to exploration in modeling
and how it's very important, or have I have
found it to be very important for understanding
and improving the quality of information that
comes out of high throughput measurement.
I've been working for the last 15 years mainly
in genomics with developing statistical methodology
for measurements that come out of new technologies,
such as microarrays, next generation sequencing,
and it's different applications, because these
technologies have many different applications
and for each one, different
statistical challenges come up. And it's been
a data science since I've started. The problems
are very much driven by the data. People are
using data to discover new things. So even
before that term became widely popular, people
in genomics were big into data science.
All right, so there's much more information
on my web page of what I want to talk about,
and also I make announcements on Twitter about
new research papers, new courses, and other
things. So here's a course that was-- here's
a link to the course that was described. It's
free. It's a free course. You can take it
self-paced. There's currently seven different
courses that go in order of difficulty, starting
with the simplest one, where introductory
statistics is presented along with R code
to be able to implement that knowledge.
There's also a book that goes along with that
course. It's also free. You can get it on
Leanpub, and it comes out as a PDF. If you
want a hard copy, that's not free and you
can get it on Amazon. And one nice thing about
the book is that it basically-- the code,
you need to reconstruct the book with all
the data analysis in it is included on GitHub.
There's links to it within the book. So you
can not only read it and learn statistics,
and computing, and coding in R, but also you
recreate the book and learn it that way.
All right, so just need to get started, I
wanted to go back to the most simplest concept
in inference, and those that already know
this, bear with me. It will only like five
minutes. And basically, what I'm going to
do is explain what the little stars on top
of the buildings with the antenna that we
see in scientific papers means. So that's
what they put on the graph to relay that it's
statistically significant.
So I'm going to just go over that for five
minutes and then explain some subtleties how
this has come up in my research. So to give
a very simple example, suppose we have two
groups, and basically just to make it simple,
I'm going to use men and women and heights.
And what I have is a population of men and
women. You can take the mean of the man and
the mean of women, and those two means may
or may not be different, but suppose we don't
know. We come from outer space and we don't
know that that's the case. So we want to know,
and we could just measure everybody and come
up with an answer, or we could take a sample.
So if we take a sample of 10 people of 10
of each, we then get data. So here's what
it would look like. Here's an example of a
sample. This is an actual sample that I took
with using pre-measured heights, and we can
see that there's a difference between men
and women. Men are taller by three inches
in this sample. So inference is the part of
statistics that helps you understand if this
is-- how much can this very, and how consistent
this is with the actual means being the same
or different.
So we basically are interested in the means
of the population. So we look at the sample
means and then use that to try to answer the
question. So here's one way to see inference,
to understand inference. So we did it once.
I'm just going to do it for the mean heights,
not for the difference for now.
The important concepts to get here is that
every time we take a sample the mean changes.
Here's the mean of men for the first sample
I took, but if I take another one, it will
be a different one. I'm going to start making
a histogram where these height's pile up,
and you see that we get different values every
time, and we do it a million times. We eventually
you get a distribution of the heights, of
the average heights.
And we can see how much it varies. It varies
from around 67 to about 71, as for 95% of
the data is, of the outcomes are. This tells
us, wait a minute, we saw a difference, but
it could have been different. How different
could it have been? Well, this distribution
helps us understand that, and that's the general
principle behind inference. But understanding
that the population has variability, and that
there's tall men and short men, et cetera,
and the fact that we take a sample results
in the average heights having variability
as well.
So if we make the sample bigger, this is one
of the things we learn statistic classes,
then the variance of that mean gets smaller.
So you can see that this distribution is not
as fat. So this is what you statistic classes,
that that mean and those means, both for men
and woman, is going to be approximately normal
with the population mean, standard deviation
divided by the square root of the sample size.
The way we use this in biology very often
is by constructing a t statistic, and we can
do it using some mathematics. Once we model
them, we know how much that t statistic should
vary just by chance, and from there we get
P values, and confidence intervals, et cetera.
So that's just a reminder of what we're talking
about here. Sometimes we don't assume normality,
we use a model and assume the t distribution.
I'm not getting into that yet.
OK. So, I'm going to give you an example of
how that simple concept has-- this was a research
activity of mine a long time ago, and this
actually keeps coming up, but how the concept
was not being clearly understood by collaborators
and other people publishing papers, and we
did a little experiment to kind of point out
the problem. So I'm going to give you an example,
and it relates to the decision sometimes made
by biologists or experimental biologists to
pool their samples to reduce variance.
OK, so here's an experimental design that
is very common in biology. Let's say now,
let's talk about gene expression. That's one
of the topics that I work in. So we have a
microarray and we're going to get gene expression
for 12,000 genes. For each gene we get 12
measurements. Now I'm going to just focus
the discussion on if we had just one gene
or two genes. We have several mice. What we
want to find out is if a gene is differentially
expressed in two different strains.
So we follow the procedure we just talked
about with the heights. We get 12 mice of
each strain, we're going to measure the gene
expression for a given gene, and then try
to answer that question. So if we say yes,
then we say yes, this is differentially expressed,
then what we're saying is if you do this experiment
in your lab, you will also
see it be different. That's kind of what we're
saying.
Many of my collaborators were doing something
that actually kept them from answering that
question. How was that the case? Because they
pooled the data. They pooled the data from
the 12 mice, and then they created four technical
replicates. When I asked why, they will say
because that reduces the variance. OK, if
you're doing that, that means you don't understand
statistical inference, and I'm going to explain
why that is. This is the experimental design.
We take 12 measurements with 12 mice, pool
them, and then create four replicates of the
pool.
Once you do that, you will not see the variability
across the mice. Imagine if you're doing this
with heights, that would be taking 10 men,
measuring their height, measuring their heights
10 times, and then reporting the average of
the 10 four times. So if you just presented
this to someone who didn't know anything about
heights, they would think that there's no
tall men and short men. There's just one man,
and there's a little bit of measurement error
when we measure it.
So here's an example. This is not a cartoon.
This is data from the experiment of two of
the genes in the microarray. These are two
genes that when they look at, they compare
the two groups, the two pairs of four replicates
that were coming from technical replicas.
These four and four, that's how you see four
points, four and four. We get these two genes
with very, very small t values, the chance
of seeing something like this by chance using
this t statistic we just described is very,
very small. It's definitely significant. Both
genes are like that.
So we write we write a paper and we say, these
two [INAUDIBLE] expressed. If someone else
runs this experiment, are they going to see
this again when they do it? And the answer
is we actually don't know. Why not? Because
now I'm going to show you the original data.
Now I'm going to show you this. This is actually
an experiment we ran to kind of make this
point. I'm actually going to share this data,
because in the experiment we ran, we actually
kept both. We kept these 12 measurements,
these 12 measurements, these four, and these
four.
So now look at those two things. So that is
now telling a very different story. The first
gene has a lot of variability, and the second
one has less variability. This is a much--
you say it's more consistent. So now when
I do it like this, only the second gene has
a significant p-value. The first one doesn't.
So if someone ran this experiment again, they
would actually not confirm gene one, but they
probably will if they have enough power. They
probably will confirm gene two.
So the lesson here is you want to see the
variation because for the inference you're
doing, it is important. It's part of the framework
of inference that you do for this. This is
something that comes up over and over again,
where the variability that's important to
inference is not understood and many mistakes
are made because of that error. So here are
the two genes next to each other. There's
another example, I think, of two things that
are like that
where one is very consistent, the other one
isn't, but when you pool you don't really
get to see that.
We actually wrote a paper on this. It's not
just about this. It has other things I experiment.
It's about experimental designs, when you
need to pool-- in that case, it actually explains
this in more detail, and it's published in
2005 in PNAS. OK. So one of the morals of
the story of that particular example is that
the biological variability, it's much bigger
than technical variability. I think that's
going to be common in many, many of the measurement
technologies that we have in big data and
biology in general. That we're going to get
more and more precise technical measurements,
but human variability, or whatever we're measuring,
won't go away.
Another thing I would like to mention in our
class about inference, in a talk about inference,
is the multiple comparison problem. This is
obvious to most, but I still see papers coming
out that do not correct for multiple comparisons
in any way, and so I want to just briefly
mention it. I guess I just awkwardly use these
slides. I'll just described describe the problem.
In the case of gene expression, you have high
throughput-- sorry, in the case of high throughput
technology, we are-- and we're trying to find,
say, differential expression, differentially
expressed genes. It could be other things.
It could be differentially methylated CPGs,
it could be differentially binding transcription
factor binding sites, et cetera.
We're exploring a big space. We're testing
my hypothesis. That's how a statistician would
say it, and one thing to keep in mind is that
if you test 10,000 hypotheses and you restrict
the genes you report, or whatever units you
report to 5% p-value, you're going to get
500 incorrect reportings when the null hypothesis
is true.
So if you don't understand-- many of you probably
are thinking, yeah, I know that, but if you
don't know exactly what I'm talking about
here, definitely go read up on multiple comparison.
We have a course that covers it. It's in the
book, but there's many other books and other
courses it that describe ti.
All right, so that's the first part of the
talk. I know it was very basic. Now, I want
to go to some more complicated topics, the
complex topics, where statistical modeling
has helped and also exploratory data analysis,
which is I know it's not in the title of the
topic, but it's as important or perhaps more
important, I think, in the analysis of what
today we're calling big data. I'll do through
examples in the second part.
OK, so the first thing I want to warn against
is our desire for wanting to have workflows.
This is a screenshot of what you get on Google
Images when you Google workflows and biology,
or in biomedical sciences. You get a bunch
of things like this, but if you look at them
closely, many of them basically come down
to a workflow like this, describing a way
to go from big data to knowledge. That's the
title of the graph. So you start with big
data and then you go through this process,
it's the use of boxes, and at the end there's
some list, or some figure, and
you're done. You discover something or learn
something.
One of my goals here is to remind listeners
of how important it is to think hard about
what these boxes are doing, and sometimes
make sure that they're doing what we think
we're doing. It's many times the case that
the procedures that we think are standard
procedure, and we can just stick them into
the workflow will work, and it turns out that
just by looking at a few plots, we quickly
realize that it's absolutely not the case.
That this actually leads to knowledge, instead
it leads to false positives and confusion.
So what I want to do is I want to explain
examples of where this workflow that people
were using without exploring data, just by
kind of turning the crank, we're leading to
problems. All right, so here's a quote from
John Tukey, that kind of relates to what I
just described. All right, so to motivate
this, I want to-- I also want to motivate
the improvement of the boxes in the workflow.
Not just saying we're going to keep you from
making mistakes, but we actually want to help
you make discoveries. It's not just about
being policemen or about being a Debbie downer
about what people find, but rather two things.
You'll have less false positives, but also
you will have more true positives, hopefully.
To motivate that out, I always like to go
back to the discovery of the microscope, which--
not the discovery of the microscope, the improvement
of the microscope, which led the person who
first improved the microscope enough, it led
him to become the father of microbiology.
So simply by-- no, not simply, but when people
were looking through microscopes, other scientists
were trying to discover things, but they were
seeing blurry images. He improved the microscope
and he was able to see something that nobody
else saw, and now he discovers microbes. He
discovered are many, many other things that
are microscopic because he was the only one
that could see them.
So in my field, in high throughput biology,
I feel like the data scientists are often
not just keeping people from making false
claims, but also helping people put their
data into focus and make discoveries. Here's
another quote from Tukey related to that particular
topic. When it comes to data, which is what
we look at now, we don't look through microscopes
anymore, although some people do, we look
at data. We have digital data that the data
scientists turn into images, that then biologists
or other scientists turn into knowledge or
extract knowledge from. And making figures
is exploring data, is a key component of doing
that properly.
So I'll give you now, concrete examples from
my own research related to what I just described.
I'm going to talk about two problems, two
examples, and there's many more, which I won't
have time to talk about. If you want to read
more about my own personal experience in this,
a lot of my current papers relate to this
particular topic, and you're of course, welcome
to look some of those up. And I think it's
happening all over the sciences. It's not
just in genomics. It's not just in biology,
but improvement of data analysis [INAUDIBLE]
by careful data exploration and
thinking of how to properly model data, is
leading to a lot of improvements in how we
interpret data.
OK, so here's an example. This is again, not
a cartoon, this is actual data. This is actual
experimental data. I'll explain what it is
now. So the data that I'm presenting in this
plot comes from public repositories. This
particular one is a gene expression omnibus,
and this is a great resource. It has any published
gene expression experiment is supposed to
be in either Geo, or in a European database
called Array Express.
So you can go there, and what I did for this
one is I went there I got data from five different
tissues. So there's five different tissues
represented in this figure, and I obtained
gene expression data from them from microarrays,
in this case. So that means for each sample
I have 12,000 measurements. So it's a 12,000
number vector, and I have more than five points
because for each tissue I had several individuals.
So there's about 50 points because for each
issue, I have about 10 people on average.
So I have these factors. I have about 50 factors
that are in 10,000 plus dimensions right because
I have one number for each gene. So that's
something I can't really plot, so instead
I'm going to plot the first two principal
components-- that's what I'm showing here--
of that big matrix. If you don't know what
principle components are, it's a very, very
simple explanation of one of the things you
can do with them.
Each point here represents one of the samples
that is originally 12,000 dimensions. I have
reduced it to two dimensions. It was 12,000.
And the nice property about this particular
summery is that the distance between any two
points resembles the distance between the
original 12,000 dimension vector. So now when
I have it in two dimensions, I can actually
see what's close and what's not close.
So in this plot I can see that these points
are close, and then we have these points are
close, these points are close, et cetera.
So these points are close, so I would tend
to think, well, those are probably from the
same tissues. Different tissues have different
gene expression patterns. That's one of the
reasons they become different tissues in the
first place. So I should see here, five clusters.
I don't quite see them. Now, I'm going to
reveal what the tissues are, and you can see
that it's not really what we were expecting.
So these guys that were close together are
different tissues. These are colon and these
are placenta. And we have some colons down
here that are way farther from these colons
then they are from here. So you can see how
there are problems in the data. So I would
say that this data is out of focus, or this
fact that we thought we knew about gene expression
in tissues is maybe not true. So if you just
go down the pipeline workflow, and run this
data through it, and ask for clusters, you
conclude biologists are wrong. Gene expression
between tissues is not that different, and
that would be a mistake.
So because if we then dig deeper into the
data, forget the workflow, let's go back to
the data and dig deeper into
it, we're going to find that there is a lot
of noise in the measurement. So now we're
going to take one point, and instead of just
reducing to the two dimensions, we're actually
going to look at all the data, all the 12,000
points. And this figure shows you that.
So now we have the 12,000 points. You can
see there's 12,000 little black dots, and
the plot is made in a way that reveals what
we're interested in when we look at compared
two samples to see what genes are different
and which ones are not. We have the log ratio
of the two measurements on the y-axis. So
for example, this gene is 16. It's log based
two. This gene is 16 times bigger on one sample
compared to the other, and these that are
at zero are the same. The log ratio is zero.
So this particular dataset is not one of the
ones that you just saw. This is from an experiment
that a company ran, and they were nice enough
to share it with us just to test out the technology.
And what was done for this experiment was
they took two samples that were the same.
How did they know they were the same? Because
they took one RNA sample, a vat of material
that had RNA molecules in it, and they randomly
split it into two. They just split into two
equal parts, and then they ran the experiment
on those two.
So if the technology is working well, there's
enough molecules there that things will average
out and it should be the case. And when we
compare them, when we measure gene expression
in these two, it's basically the same sample.
We should get the same answer for every gene.
So this mass of points should really be around
zero, or close to zero.
Now, you can say well, sure, there's measurement
error. OK, that's very possible. However,
the people who ran this experiment included
16 genes. These are the orange ones. They're
represented in orange here, where they knew
there were actually different. They made him
twice as big for real. They actually artificially
made them twice as big in one sample compared
to the other. So these 12 points are the ones
that should be different.
The black point should be at zero and these
black points should be at one. So this gives
you an idea of what signal looks like. This
is a problem now. If the signal is this big,
then this is a problem. Because if I gave
you this picture and I said find me the 20
most differential genes, you would probably
say, well, this one and that one, and this
one and these. These are all big. You would
never come down to these 60.
So there's a lot of noise in the data. So
why is that? Why is there so much noise in
the data? Is this just the way biology is?
Or is this the way that the technology works?
And if it doesn't, we might as well stop buying
this product. Well, so, to answer this question
one of the things we did was go even one step
further down the data. These points actually
come from even rawer data, and we read how
that was done, how they actually got to here,
and we noticed that there was some modeling
going on. There were statistical modeling
happening when they analyzed the data to get
to these points.
Here's sort of what the model was for doing
this. So what was happening is that these
measurements, the manufacturers realized that
when they were trying to measure the expression
of a specific gene, they were also measuring
background noise. So even when a gene was
not expressed, the unit that was measuring
that gene would give values, big values sometimes.
And they also noticed that different measurement
units produced different background levels,
which was a problem because now when you have
different gene expression measurements in
two different genes, the only reason you might
be seeing that is because you just had two
units that worked that way. One measured high
background, the other mentioned low background.
So they thought of it like this. The model
they thought about was like this. You wanted
to estimate gene expression, here represented
with a beta, but there's background that's
represented with the alpha, and every single
measurement, every single different measurement
unit had a different alpha. So it wasn't like
a global alpha they can remove. You had to
remove an alpha for each single measurement.
Every unit had a different one. Every measurement
unit had a different one.
If you see your measurement as seven, you
don't know if that's four plus three or two
plus five. You have no way of knowing that.
So to determine that, what they did was they
said, let's add measurement units to this
instrument that measures just the background.
So now we have two measurements. One measures
the background plus the signal, the other
one just measures the background, and what
we'll do then is we'll subtract it and we'll
get B, and we're done. Problem solved.
But here's the problem with that model. We
did another experiment just to get an idea
of how off this model was. The problem here
is that there's no stochasticity described
in the model. We ran an experiment where we
knew there was no beta. We ran an experiment
that was just a negative control, and in that
case we should just be seeing alpha and alpha.
So here's a plot of that and you can see that
it's not right on the line. It's correlated.
That's good. But it's quite a bit of noise.
This is in the log scale, so that's quite
a bit of noise that you're seeing there between
Y1 and Y2's measurement of alpha.
So the problem with this is that the actual
model should look something like this since
there's-- Now this is actually a statistical
model where there's randomness included. We
have alpha 1, alpha 2, not just alpha and
alpha. They're different quantities. They're
correlated. In the log scale, the correlations
is about 0.7. You can see that's the correlation
there is about 0.7. So if that's the case,
if that's the model, that's a model that to
us makes more sense.
That implies that if you then look at things
log rations, which is what people were using
to quantify differences in
gene expression, then the variance of the
log of that difference-- because that's what
they're using as a measurement, the difference
between Y1 and Y2. The variance of the log
of that difference we can show mathematically.
I'm not going to show you here. It's using
something called Taylor's expansion. It's
not important. We can show that variance is
proportional to the reciprocal of the signal
squared. That's mathematics. That's not biology.
That's not problems with the technology. It's
the problem with decision they made, the mathematical
decision they made of how to correct this
measurement.
So if you look at this formula, then you can
see that you see it here. If you draw a line
of the variance here, you just go by the points.
If you draw a line of the variance it would
go like that. That function is 1 over x squared.
Well, it could be. We would need some constant,
but it's very consistent with what the math
is predicting. One over b squared, one over
b squared. This would be b, right? This is
the signal. The average of the two measurements
is an approximation of the signal.
So that in mind, now that we have a model,
we can come up with a better statistical solution
that doesn't have this property. We can do
that. We have a model in place, now we can
do math and figure out, OK, what transformation
of the data would estimate data without having
a massive variance? And we might introduce
a little bit of bias just to reduce the variance,
that's one approach that is often used in
statistics. In machine learning that's called
shrinkage or regularization.
when we do that, with that in mind, we can
construct a solution based on the model, and
we can go from this plot to this plot. That's
without any new experiment, nothing new. Just
the same data processed differently. We get
rid of all that noise that we were seeing
earlier, and now if we asked you to give me
the biggest differences, you would definitely
start with some of these orange points. So
that's quite a big improvement.
Again, that was just the result of changing
the way you model the data and developed statistical
solutions for it. So that idea was turned
into software, and now today, when people
use these technologies, most-- still not everybody,
but most I would say, use a technique like
this rather than what was originally proposed.
All right, so that's one example of how statistical
models can improve measurement data that you
would then use to make this biological discovery.
For example, let's go back to the motivation
example. Here are the data that you started
with, which I would say is really out of focus
data. This is processed with the original
algorithm. Once I use this new idea that comes
from a more rigorous statistical model, you
end up with a plot that looks like this, and
that is now much more consistent with what
a biologist told us. Gene expression parents
from the same tissue are similar to each other,
and they're different from different tissues.
We see the five clusters very clearly. If
we didn't know that, we would actually discover
it because if you looked at this data without
the colors, you would be pretty sure there's
four, maybe five
clusters, and you would be onto something.
All right, so now moving on to another way
in which statistical modeling helps us. Quite
different. I like to talk about this one because
it's-- I think, currently, the biggest challenge
in genomics is dealing with what we call the
batch effect, and I suspect we're going to
see batch effects in pretty much any kind
of measurement technology that is collected
across time. You'll see what I mean as I as
I describe this.
OK, so I'm going to use an example. This is
a paper that used the standard workflow. They
followed all the best practices. They had
raw data, they processed it with the recommended
processing algorithm, they did the t-tests
correctly, then they did Bonferroni correction.
So they dealt with a multiple comparison problem
in a very conservative way, and even after
that they report. Even after that conservative
use of Bonferroni to not make type I errors,
they conclude that 1,097 of the 4,197 genes
that they tested show a statistically significant
difference between two different ethnic groups
when you measure gene expression in blood.
So that's a big number. It's contrary to what
most people would think was the case. I think
if you ask somebody before this paper was
published how many genes are differentially
expressed between two ethnic groups, they
would probably say between 0 and maybe five.
That's what I would have answered. Instead
they get 1,000. So they got their paper published
in a very prominent biological journal because
it's a surprising result.
All right, so now let's forget the workflow
and let's go back to the data and look at
it. So you can actually get this data from
Geo. This is the data from that paper. You
can see there is about 200 points, 209 I think.
So each point now, it's not a different issue,
each point is a different person, and each
person has a profile of-- they say out of
4,000, but I think the original number was
8,000 that they filter down. So this is a
technology that measured about 8,000 gene
expression genes. Mapped expression for 8,000
genes.
For each person you have a vector of 8,000,
and then we reduce it down to two, PCA just
take a first look at the data, and we can
see that the results here is very consistent
with what they were saying about 1,000 genes
being different because there is a very clear
difference between the two ethnic groups being
compared. You have the orange and it's compared
against the green. The first principal component
is very different. That to me is very consistent
with what was published.
Now, looking at this data there's something
else that catches our eye, and it's that we
see other clusters, not just the ethnic groups.
If you look closely at the orange group, which
is all the same ethnic group, you see-- I
see at least, I see a cluster here and a cluster
here, and then I move here, there's another
cluster here, and you can kind of see another
one here. But regardless of that, if this
group shows this much variation, why is this
group showing this much variation? That's
a lot more. That's double or triple.
So when we see a picture that, you start wondering
what else could explain this difference? And
in this case, there's a group of scientists.
It wasn't my group, it was another group that
decided to noted-- I don't know how they originally
noted this, but they noted that these samples
were processed across five or six years, and
it turns out that when you get the raw data
for this, you can actually get the date. It's
actually stamped on the file where the data
lives.
Now I'm going to show you the same plot. Points
aren't going to move. All I'm going to do
is change the color to represent date, year,
instead of ethnic group. OK, so now when I
do that, I can see that those two clusters
that I kind of could see before, right here
and here, one is greenish and the other one
is the orange. That's 2002 and this 2003.
So that was the moment in which these measurements
were made. Not when the people were born or
anything like that. It's just technical. Then
we see 2004 here, 2005, 2006.
So, is this variability that we see described
by-- is it really just the date? The batch?
We call them batch effects because these are
things that were processed in batches. It
wasn't just done once. So this particular
experiment, it's a little bit hard to distinguish
between ethnicity and date because it's confounded.
If you go back and forth, you see that the
orange points coincide with the green and
orange, here, and that the green coincide
with the pink. So they were basically done
in different years. So when you compare two
things, it's hard to tell is it year or is
it ethnicity?
You can do more data exploration, and if you
do I think you'll be convinced that it's probably
date what's making this so variable. Here's
one example. This is the first principal component
stratified. Now I'm going further. Instead
of year, I'm doing it by month. So this is
one ethnic group, here, all these orange ones,
and you can see that the first principle component
drops dramatically in February of 2003, and
then it drops again in April, and then it
kind of stays there. So maybe they were buying
boxes of whatever-- we don't know what it
was, but you can definitely see that there's
a big change within the group, which is explained
by month.
So when I see a picture like this, I say well,
I want to do this experiment again. I want
to balance everything and see if I get a different
answer. All right, so now let's explain this
with inference and statistical modeling, this
batch effect, which is ubiquitous in high
throughput technology measurements and beyond.
One thing I should mention as an aside, we
can see the batch effect very clearly in high
throughput technology. In low throughput technologies,
it's not always obvious, but it's harder to
see if it is there.
So in a way, high throughput technologies
maybe being negatively affected because of
the fact they reveal something. Because they're
more informative, you actually can see the
problems. When it's not as informative, it's
low throughput, you might be there, but you
don't see it. So don't think this is just
a problem with high throughput data, it's
just that we can see it with high throughput
data. I'm going to give you an example of
a low throughput
experiment that had a huge batch effect in
a second.
All right, so here's a general-- just write
it down with the inference model, with a statistical
modeling approach of why this is a problem,
and I'm going to write it in more general
terms. So I'm interested in the difference
between two groups. In this case, it was too
ethnic groups, but it could be something else.
We earlier did two strains of mice, and before
that we did two sexes or genders.
So you have two groups, group one and group
two, and we're going to take several measurements
for each one. We're going to take several
individuals from each one. So that's what
the i is indexing. So we have several measurements
for one, several measurements for two, and
what I am assuming is that-- or the way I'm
modeling this is that there there's this mean.
There's a mean value for that group, alpha,
and then there's differences between individuals,
which are described with this term here. This
is sometimes called measurement error, but
in the case of heights or gene expression,
it's other things. It's not just measurement
error in the case of heights. Some people
are tall so they have a big epsilon, some
people are short so they have a negative epsilon.
OK, then the second group has the same mean,
and perhaps, that's what we're going to test,
it has a difference that is parametrized with
the beta, and then they also have measurement
error. So what I'm looking for, I'm looking
for genes or-- in the previous case, I was
looking for genes that had betas different
from zero, and reporting those. All right,
so how do I find beta? We already went over
this, but here we go again.
The difference between the two means of the
two groups is going to be approximately beta.
The alphas cancel out. The epsilons average
out to zero if we take enough measurements.
So this is approximately beta, than what we
did with the t-test is to go further and say,
well, it's beta, but we also know that it
has a standard error, which has to do with
the population variance and the size of the
sample. So that's the standard statistical
approach to doing this, and that's what that
was done for the previous example we talked
about when they were looking for genes that
were different in the two groups.
Now, when you have a batch effect, that model
is no longer correct. Instead-- and here I'm
showing an example where the batch effect
was confounded, meaning that group one was
done in one batch, group two was in another
batch. So this W that I'm showing you here,
is the potential difference introduced by
being in a different batch. Note that there's
no i. So each batch has its own mean value.
So if I have this, if this is my correct model
then I have a problem because this is no longer
the case. This should be alpha, sorry, this
guy here. The alphas no longer cancel out.
I'm sorry, the alphas do cancel out, the epsilons
still average out to zero, but these W's,
they stay. So when I look at the difference
in the average, what I'm seeing
is-- the difference I'm interested in plus
the difference in the average values introduced
by the batches.
So if I look at these differences and I see
a five, I don't know if it's two plus three,
or zero plus five, or five plus zero. I have
no way of distinguishing that. I have no information.
I have no way of separating that when it's
completely confounded. That's the problem
with confounding batches with outcomes, and
unfortunately that happens a lot in these
experiments where they get all the controls,
and they run them first, and they then get
all the treatments and run a second. I see
it all the time, this is the type of confounding.
Another way to think about this, for those
that are more advanced statistically, is to
think that these Ws are random variables,
so it's like a random effect that each batch
introduces. It's the same across batches,
so the way that this is then turns into a
description of the problem is that the variance
that we estimated for our estimate is bigger
than the variance due to W, than what we actually
use for a t-test, which is just this component.
So when we construct a t-test with this variance,
were underestimating the variance, and therefore
our t-test are bigger than they should. That's
another way to thinking about this.
OK, so here's an example. Earlier I said this
is not specific to high throughput. Here's
an example from physics experiments from the
last century. This is data that you can get
from a paper. They're published in Technometrics
by Yuden in 1972. He actually has a table
of these values, and I turned them into a
figure. And they are the reported estimates
of the astronomical unit along with a confidence
interval.
So this is what today we think is the astronomical
unit, is shown here with this dash line, and
here is the first experiment-- at least in
this paper was reported, and then here's the
second one, and we can see that the speed
of light-- there's something wrong with either
the estimates or the confidence intervals,
or the speed of light changed in 1900. And
you can see it happen again, right? Because
this is definitely statistically significant.
Here is it again, it changes again in 1920,
the speed of light changed.
So that is a problem, and if we just looked
at this guy with no other information, we
wouldn't know what's going on. But once we
make the whole plot, now he turned it into
a high throughput experiment with many labs
measuring it, we see the problem, and it's
that there's a lab effect. It's a batch effect.
Depending on what lab did it, we get a deviation
from what today is considered to be the right
answer.
The lab that we're measuring these, within
their lab they can't see that they have this
batch effect, so the confidence intervals
that they report are much smaller than what
they should be. So here's another way to think
about it. This variance that we see here is
estimated as a measurement error variance.
So we get it from within the experiment. That
would be the variance of the measurement error,
while the batch effect variance, w, is much
bigger. That's why the points are varying
all over the place.
All right. There are some solutions that have
been developed for this problem. They're on
something called factor analysis. It's actually
a very old technique from the early 1900s,
and the reason that this technique is widely
used is because when we look at the data--
this is a plot of the correlations between
the 200 individuals from the previous example,
and you can see that there's blocks of groups
that are more correlated to each other.
This must be the first two years, and this
is like 2005 because you can see these blocks
of time, but then there's sub blocks. There's
all this structure. We see tight red dots,
not as tight, but somewhat pinkish big squares.
So there's a structure in the data that is
induced by some kind of weird grouping that
has to do with date, but it's not clear that
it's just date. So when you have a problem
like that, factoring analysis, it tries to
estimate this structure and then take it into
account when you're doing the analysis. So
I'm going to try to explain that in five minutes
so that we can finish with five minutes for
questions.
And to describe this approach and give you
an idea of how complex this is, I'm going
to use a subset of the earlier data set of
200 people. I'm going to take 24 of them.
I'm going to take 12 men, and 12 females,
and 12 males. So you can see the experimental
design here. I'm going to confound date, but
not completely. So these techniques work when
they-- if something is completely confounded,
we currently don't have any solutions, but
if it's not, you can use statistical models
to help.
You can see the confounding here. More males
were measured in June than females, and more
females were measured in October than males.
All right, so this plot-- this is not a cartoon.
This is, again, actual data from the experimental
data. You can see genes. I have selected some
genes. And I'm not showing you all 8,000,
and you can see the y-axis up here-- sorry,
the Y chromosome up here. These are genes
on the Y chromosome. Males are high, females
and low because females don't have a Y chromosome.
All right, so there are the 12 man and the
12 women, and 12 males, 12 females, and these
are genes on the Y chromosome.
Then we see other genes and there's no difference.
You can see some variability, and then down
here you can see the dates. These are genes
that are affected by the batch effect. So
let's look at that. So can you tell where
June is? You can see it here. See this square
here? There's nine people here, nine men.
These nine men were done in June, they're
right here, and then these three men, they're
right here. They're blue. So you see October
and June. This is June and October. For the
females, there's three in June and 9 in October.
So you can see batch effect.
So what happens if I do a t-test now, just
ignoring this? If I compare this side to that
side, these are going to be super significant,
but so are these because there's more red
here than over here. This is another way of
writing out the t-test model. If I assume
this, this area is going to cause problems
for me. If I make a histogram of pvalues I
get a lot of significant genes. When I look
at the autosome genes, I'm really not expecting
many, or any at
all. It's driven probably by the fact that
we have a difference between June and October.
So, you can see the sample correlations again
here. Here's the original ordering with females
and males, ordered right like that. The correlation
is not explained by it, it's explained by
date. So if I order them by date, you can
see June and October, that there's two big
red boxes. There's more correlation in the
ones within October, more correlation than
the ones in June, but we can't just model
it as June in October because there's sub
groups. So there's another subgroup here that
apparently ended in October 23, or right before,
or in the morning of June 23, and then it
stops, and then there's another little box
here. We can see some tiny-
Basically what I'm saying is it's not as simple
as just dates. There's some other thing going
on. What factor analysis does is it tries
to estimate this structure. So what we do
is we add another component, it's a linear
component, for those that know what I mean
by that, and it basically tries to model this
structure with a linear model where you're
actually estimating the matrix that describes
the variability. This is a little more complicated.
PCA works for estimating these components,
and that's what basically factor analysis
does.
The reason there's publications in 2007 as
opposed to just saying let's just use factor
analysis because we have to now distinguish
between being a model-- we have to model the
part that has to do with the biology that
we care about. So we want to estimate the
difference between males and females.
We don't want that to just be thrown into
the factor part, and then we model this part
down here with a factor model, and then estimating
and fitting this model is complicated, and
that's why there's publications because there's
different approaches for doing this and different
techniques. There's several papers. But here's
the result of applying one of them. This is
now flattened out. That's good, it means it
removed most of the genes that we think were
due to the batch effect. That's what happens
when you apply this model to this data. We
reduce the number of false positives by 100.
So here's what it's doing. This factor analysis
approach is splitting the data up into the
differences due to sex. You can see them up
here. I think these are two false positives,
or maybe not. But you have the two differences
in sex, then you have the batch effect here,
and now you have the measurement error over
here. So it breaks down the data pretty well
into the different parts.
All right, so-- is that repeated? It is repeated,
sorry. So this is all we have. We wrote a
review on these methods. It was published
about five years ago, maybe more, and you
can go read it. It's described in relatively
simple terms so that you can be aware of what
the problem is, and some of the solutions
that exist. But this is an area of current
research. In fact, I'm doing a lot of research
today related to solving that problem in different
technologies. Three examples listed here.
If you want to see more, you can follow--
I'll announce whatever we put out on Twitter,
and also at some point the links go up on
our web page.
All right, so I want to stop there and thank
some of the people that helped me with the
research I described today, and of course
the NIH for funding a lot of this work. OK,
that's the end.
Great. Thank you Dr. Irizarry for this wonderful
start to section four for our data science
seminars. I think we have time for one quick
question. It's a little bit of a provocative
question, but the question is related to sort
of the natural tension that exists between
exploratory data analysis and knowledge discovery,
and whether there's sort of-- what is the
sort of natural balance between discovering
knowledge simply through data science and
needing additional confirmatory analyses or
experiments? Could you comment a little bit
on that maybe?
Me? Oh, sure. The way I work, I always work
with collaborators that understand the context
and the substance-- I shouldn't say substance,
but the subject matter that we're studying,
and that helps creates-- greatly helps make
sure that what we're finding makes some sense,
that it has some explanations that are grounded
in existing knowledge. And of course, we definitely
encourage our collaborators to do confirmation
analyses when possible. I'm a big believer
on confirmation and on replication.
I like the way that science becomes the--
what's the word that's used? The scientific
consensus, the way that we come to in the
United States today, it's not just papers
published and we believe it. It's not two
papers are published and we believe it. It
usually takes much more than that. It sometimes
takes a group of experts convened by the National
Academy to sit down and read everything that's
been published, think hard, and put out some
statement.
So in general, I think that the person who
asked that question is worried that we just
we explore the data and find some serendipitous
result and publish it. I don't think that's
how we should do it. We should definitely
collaborate with experts, and we should also
confirm and look to future papers to see if
our results are confirmed or not.
But with that said, I'm a big believer that
data exploration can lead to discovery, and
also on the other side, it can also lead to
the discovery of problems, of issues with
something that's been published because the
data had problems that weren't caught by the
standard workflow. So I hope that answers
the question.
No, I think that's a great answer and certainly
insightful. I think looking at the body of
work, rather than just a single sort of discovery
is really how science operates today, and
I think that's an important point that you've
made. So thank you again, so much for your
time, and for giving this talk. We're at 10:00,
so we'll conclude here.
Great, thank you. Bye bye.
Bye.